welcome to my video series of bio
techniques explained in five minutes or
less where I explain biology concepts
within five minutes or even less time so
if you haven't yet subscribed to my
channel just quickly hit that subscribe
button in this installment we would
discuss immunohistochemistry so as the
name suggests immuno it has something to
do with the antibodies histo means it
has something to do with tissues and
cells and chemistry so antigen-antibody
reaction is somehow important for this
technique so immunohistochemistry
technique is used for a variety of
purposes that we would learn now you
might be familiar with this kind of
images of cells tissues stained with
antibodies and specific cellular markers
sometimes which highlight cellular
architecture sometimes protein
distribution etc now
immunohistochemistry can be widely used
in different techniques including to
visualize protein localization to
visualize life processes like cell
division to visualize several cell
signaling aspects to trace cell
signaling pathways and also to trace
cell morphology and determining cellular
architecture so these are a few of the
ways by which immunohistochemistry could
be used in biology now the heart of the
immunohistochemistry process is
detection of an protein more precisely
an epitope which is a part of the
protein by antibody so our antibody is
generated against a specific epitope so
it is destined to recognize a specific
epitope and we call this primary
antibody and against the primary
antibodies if see region there is a
secondary antibody which recognized the
FC region of the primary antibody as an
antigen and bind to it oftenly
the secondary antibody is linked with a
fluorophore so that allows us to get a
fluorescence based detection otherwise
secondary antibodies could be also
enzyme linked and that could give us a
colorimetric detection apart
these variants there are other ways
where there could be antibodies which
are primary antibodies but they are
conjugated with fluorophore
or an enzyme more or less they're the
same way but they're way way WAY
costlier so people people prefer to use
a combination of primary antibody and
secondary antibody so have you ever
wondered where does this primary
antibody is coming from so let's say you
want to use an antibody against a
protein a so you generate this epitope
and inject that into a host in this case
the mouse and the mouse would produce
itself antibody producing spleen cells
inside it spleen so you extract some
spleen cells from that Mouse and fuse it
with a cancer cell line known as myeloma
cell line to produce something called
hybridoma the high pro doma our antibody
working like antibody producing
factories and they would produce
antibodies and these antibodies are then
collected purified and used for
immunohistochemistry now the secondary
antibodies are generated in a similar
manner in case of generation of
secondary antibodies the antigen that is
injected into the host is the FC region
of the primary antibody and here is the
process of antibodies staining or here
is the process of immunohistochemistry
but the first step involves
permeabilization of the cell so the cell
membrane is there so antibody might have
difficulty to getting inside so in order
to get rid of that problem we wash it
with mild detergent like triton x along
with buffer like PBS to permeable eyes
the cell membrane a little bit such that
antibody can get in and that most of the
cases the antigen which is the epitope
sitting in somewhere in the cytosol or
in specific organelles or in nucleus
they could be accessible to the
antibodies now second step is blocking
blocking is an important step because it
it reduced the chance of nonspecific
binding then primary antibody is in
you baited with the epitope if epitope
is there it is expected that the primary
antibody would bind to that epidural now
then the process come of adding the
secondary antibodies and this process
has to be done in dark so the secondary
antibodies would recognize the epitope
of primary antibodies tail that means FC
region now if primary antibody is there
that means the epitope is there and if
the secondary antibody is there that
means also the primary antibody is there
so this relay of detection can tell us
about presence of an epitope in a sample
so this is how and the last step is
detection of the signal using a
fluorescence microscope that would tell
us about the localization of a protein
or let's say cellular architecture the
distribution of a protein and many more
so this is how immunohistochemistry is a
useful technique specially in cell
biology developmental biology and
neurobiology and even all of the fields
of biology so if you liked my video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
Like share and subscribe thank you